hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
I'm glad you can see my degradation and
slide into madness catalog so plainly
for everyone to see so now what I'm
gonna do is a nice one two three four I
you know I could try easy but you know
I'm good what I want is a sense of
accomplishment you know actually my
little OCD I want this to be four three
two one I want to get a high score of
four and then I'm gonna quit immediately
if I die on easy before getting four
levels I am going to lose my mind I will
break my switch I will break everything
in this room it is hot in my room I am
about just what I need I'll be right
back hope nothing bad happens while I'm
away
I'm back hey how's it going everybody
got a cut on my forehead and with these
glasses I'm turning into Harry Potter I
just need to shake it up I'm fine
everything is fine my first level
seabass see this is easy stop yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes no no I don't
have any of my tickle the fire you can't
no okay I'm just gonna sneak under when
they're jumping I just got to sneak
under okay guys I'm gonna skip these
it's very tempting but I'm gonna save
them because I'm gonna need them okay
two can play the fire game maybe I
should just run oh no it's not broken
back there why why is it not broken out
oh whatever
my hitting you whew okay well you know
the way okay I can't even go through you
there it's just like a bouncy block okay
go
hey I got a buddy to come on do a big
jump oh don't do that
oh come on you there we go good enough
hey wait I didn't open the door don't
mind the fact that I'm a life down on
easy that's besides the point so let's
just keep moving forward because that's
how I roll this looks great love it low
gravity we was that thing wow I didn't
even know they had like a space-themed
one that's so cool
alright you know everything's forgiven I
feel so much better
wait why are you how are you I stole
your brain I did that I don't know oh
that's cool it's probably like some
mario galaxy themed thing but since they
have to have an nes version it's cool
this is cool
I'm not just a sucker for saying that
cuz it's space but this is cool
oh god that's only the halfway point oh
my god this has been taking forever okay
I mean it's cool and all but man it's
get a little stale come on where's the
fast-paced action and I just trying to
get to four come on oh my god oh my oh
my oh okay here's the action I guess Wow
okay do I even get a chance to kill you
or as this all just gonna go kaboom when
I touch this thing here okay I
there-there's bloated
they ask bloated they they gone whoo -
in the bag I'm gonna feel so good about
myself
what rank am I am I not even ranked why
am I not ranked where's my ranking beef
them all reach the goal after defeating
all three dry bones I didn't know you
had criteria for level oh that's
why oh wow that's so cool I didn't know
this is possible
that's cool oh I thought that was gonna
be like a big yo she's huge hey listen
you oh oh wow I can have you thank you
No Oh No BAM burger burger burger all
right okay all right
get blown all right this is so cool they
added in like there's a lot of stuff
that they've added in that I am not
aware of because I don't make these
levels so obviously how do I know about
it in any way shape or form this one's a
puzzle okay so if I'm I'm reading the
room right there like a red switch or
something
[Music]
wait of course of course of god red
bricks okay wait wait for and oh well
never mind then
BAM yes I love it I love it
this is cool honestly I was in a I was
in a bit of a tizzy okay I was a little
dizzy yes but feeling good now feeling
good now feeling real good now look how
good I feel boom that's to a-pluses
right there
new high score what what brain K my HD
tennis I don't know what that means Oh
oh it's pong it is basically pong that's
crazy that actually work that actually
what it actually works that's crazy
that's nuts
that's so cool this what that's so cool
I mean I know that people were making a
lot of these levels and making them in
good ways before but it's like why it's
so cool that's really cool I'm sorry
it's very cool
all right so that's four so now I just
need to need to fail on this next one or
I'm gonna quit I did it your progress
will be saved
oh all right I got the goo goo onesie I
got goo goo onesie are you telling me I
got goo goo one seat where's my goo goo
onesie Google onesie I thought it was
gonna be made of goo not a baby baby's
onesie
they look like you've got a full diaper
okay that stays alright okay perfect now
people can be thoroughly disturbed when
they come across me in the multiplayer
arena but what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go back to expert which is what I wanted
to do originally so I'm gonna do that
and I'm actually gonna do good oh I
don't like that or your face up there
Richie boy I can do expert that was a
mistake it was a horrible error what
have I done I don't know what's
happening I have no idea what's
happening
[Music]
excuse my right okay all right so all I
got to do is be precise and jump from
that very top tip eeeh stop point the
tip top iasts point I've used myself I
[Music]
forgot I'm back on expert October I work
if they keep tilting stop no no max P I
didn't hit max okay all right oh yeah oh
yes oh yes mama
perfect excellent yes I know I am
incredible bit okay so far so good
P Y down I don't trust you
should've trusted you so far so goo
uh-huh okay not sure what the dealio is
I feel like that was a bit unnecessary
and they're overly brutal okay what's
all this about huh what's this about huh
don't be a troll don't you troll me
don't oh oh what is this then all right
good
I guess sister quince actually means
something right like the coins actually
there I got a Lulu for the next one I'm
gonna go back to story mode and I'm
actually gonna like see if there's a way
to do games like this where it's like
you know you got to do stuff and things
for rewards I'd feel good about myself
right I feel like I got to feel good
[Music]
[Laughter]
justify my existence mice add some
resistance where I'm playing Mario maker
and having a terrible got a pathetic
okay all right
what are we doing nothing act I guess
nothing I guess a whole lot of nothing
huh Oh as dork I'm in the middle of the
darkness why is it filled with nothing
but darkness here no that's why wait
it was a mistake no please not like this
okay I hate you is it just gonna be more
boo
is it gonna be more bullet bills
oh my god it is a shark oh god why did I
go back again why would I go back again
why would I go back twice to die in the
way that was very obviously the way that
was gonna kill me why did I go back
again I mean it's like fool me twice
shame on you fool me thrice shame on Meg
what's over here oh I need the bullet
bill don't I know I don't know oh god no
not that okay I'm on just like an idiot
or something I've got to be some kind of
stupid I forgot that hurts my bones my
sweet bones
[Music]
don't be stupid mark that's all I ask
just don't be stupid for once in your
existence
don't be stupid
don't be stupid all right there we go
I've now unleashed the red what hath
that done for me I know not what I go
this way
blammo
I don't trust but lurking behind maybe
worse okay yay yay give me that
checkpoint I'll take that blank or die
now I know I know what I'm doing
ain't gonna die there's no way look at
me not dying here we go give me you oh I
didn't want to do that but this would
happen so I guess eyes got to be
relatively not too upset I'm sorry what
oh the turtle that's right it's still
alive I didn't forget about that I fir I
did all right let's do this
I'm out of here baby gimme God here we
go I think I need you for something I
just don't know what why can't I quit
you a nice sense now
I know what I must do
there we go now we got it now got it
good
all right now I know what I am doing now
we have this on lock as people say I
[Music]
swear I don't want to lose my mind I
don't know why that's my argument I
swear I don't want to lose my mind my
only defense why is that my one true
defense that makes no sense that's
that's the worst okay
that's the worst defense I've ever heard
of I'll forgive myself I'm such a nice
guy ha boom all right it's going good
guys I don't know where this leads but I
guess I'll go up here what's up here
nothing I could have gone here at any
moment
all right Oh what's all this then
nothing nothing okay so what am I
supposed to do I guess I could make it
yeah could I if I run as fast as I can
nope that's wrong okay so that ain't the
right answer as it turns out that's I
previously suspected oddly enough it is
not the correct answer
so what do I do I didn't even need to go
there so why did I go there I can blow
that up and then they can walk with me
walk with me hey hey walk with me talk
with me
hey lean with me walk with me ah sorry
is it just I gotta just my glasses hey
how you doing hey look he's my little
buddy oh yeah little bomb by really you
ain't you cuter I might use you and I'm
gonna kill you here we go
yay all right I did it I'm the best oh
crap I need to do it again I really got
to go through it all like do you really
really want me all right I'll do it
whatever okay your friends in a cat you
scoundrel out you scamp I got I got
getting oh well you know what hey you
know it's okay it's okay it's okay hey
you know I'm a forgiving dude you're not
even follow me you're just you're just
going for it okay oh well little scary a
little scary point okay
and in run come along here all your
friends are down this oh yeah I'm safe
all right
oh no I let him get that close your
friends are safe yeah they're safe down
here right in here just up up your
little noggin in there and uh yeah
you're you're gonna be with your friends
for uh for all eternity all eternity
I like the backwards slide very stylish
very stylish and but off-key Borowski
and vados ski whatever that did yeah
that's what I call good maybe that was
like something like I know Mario maker
programming is a thing so if like people
do it can set up flags and things like
that to create variables and bullcrap
like that I mean they can do some pretty
crazy stuff boy oh is that than just oh
who was that oh okay you're just down
there now okay really I'm not sure
whether it's taken me this is a long one
is the thing oh okay
oh I didn't know I could do that before
I tried that it didn't give me the okay
whatever I guess I just didn't hit it
right okay sure
BAM nothing could survive my nog all
right where do I go with this now oh
[Music]
[ __ ] okay oh okay we gotta go I I wasted
too much time I think I gotta go back
not that way maybe I could hit this
checkpoint at me I probably not a good
idea I'm gonna do it anyway back go down
here I don't think that was a good idea
to that checkpoint no no not in here not
in here there's nothing for me but that
I don't remember which way to go I be
able to go up in this way but I'm gonna
ride time I don't remember if there was
a place where I needed to bash blocks oh
you know how to get out of here oh no
this is wrong oh no it's all wrong no
this is wrong oh no it's wrong
oh it's wrong it's I needed to go no I
don't know which ways faster to get back
do I need to get that on or off or I
don't remember what's up here Oh
whop bees can you hurt me not today not
today okay I back this way maybe no this
back the way I came
where buzz go oh oh
twenty-three seconds okay well it's been
nice knowing me I had a good run
completely lost but you know good run
pretty good anyway I have no idea what
if those do where I'm supposed to go was
it in here but this is where I got the
spiky is where I got it for me what do
you want from me
oh good
good thing I'm there holy crap okay I
just gotta get the helmet and I got to
do what the helmet is meant to do which
everyone knows and we all know is there
a way I can bring a bomb right here
that's the question I got right now cuz
there's a bomb here that falls down and
then just as down there oh wait a minute
oh no I can't oh this is a mistake oh no
oh no oh no I made it no don't start no
not at the beginning no I needed to get
oh I hate you I hate you I hate you
alright sucks losing my fragile hold on
my wood sword my sanity
obviously I've lost my intelligence long
ago but my sanity that is what concerns
I'm looking for something to tell me
where I'm supposed to go but I seeing
nothing you know what I mean I'm here
but I ain't listening oh no you don't
know you don't god damn you
oh my god made it with perfect perfect
miss with perfect perfection made it I
made it okay I just gonna get through
the bomb parts
gimme mush thank you kaboom hey you come
with me okay that's annoying yeah you
keep walking yeah you keep walking and
kaboom I'm back okay I'm back to exactly
where I was all right so now I just need
to get the spiky helmet and I'm still
lost but at least I'm not so
unbelievably lost that I have no idea
what I'm doing damn it that might have
been it no it can't be the only way that
kid that would that would be a Chiti way
but I don't think that would be the only
way there's gotta be like a different
way or someone that doesn't feel right
there's only so many ways to go after
this it's all basically the same oh come
on oh come on oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] off
there's no way there'd be enough time to
run a bomb all the way over there's no
way I guess I had a lot more time than I
thought I did I thought I thought it was
gonna blow up maybe maybe may maybe but
this is a stretch all right so here we
go this is the big test I'm gonna hold
on to it this time I thought it was she
was gonna blow at any second but
apparently not
okay so I just gotta get up Oh God
you freaking [ __ ] okay so I just
can't be sprinting down the way it's
produced come on [ __ ] are you kidding me
are you kidding me are you kidding me
are you kidding me
five oh I don't think this is the right
way but my god I'm gonna actually give
it a try okay here we go
just jump and chuck it here we go oh my
god oh did the thing it's is the thing
that's what it did it in it did it
Oh Moon Moon hi moon hey hey oh my god
[Music]
Wow
first clear
and there were people that tried that
there are people that tried that Wow
Wow okay do you know what actually I
think that's good enough for me right
there for now I can save my progress on
this one but holy crap parent and child
skirt no thanks I'm good but thank you
everybody so much for watching
whew I felt good see that's the sense of
satisfaction I was craving I feel good
but they aren't you happy for me I feel
good so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more there's
plenty more Mario maker that I have done
in the past and there will be more in
the future if you guys would like some
let me know down below and thank you for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
you